[Music]
okay glass help it looks like you're
hungry GPS history tells me you rarely
leave the house
here are some local restaurants with
delivery options it looks like you're
having trouble urinating this video
footage of a waterfall hanging out again
with your mom on a Saturday night I
predict a point zero zero zero zero
three chance of you not dying alone
[Applause]
gorges are orange you look terrible
naked
is that weird torn you might I see
you're trying to tie a noose I provided
instructions on the left side of the
screen and since you won't be seeing the
remaining movies in your Netflix queue
due to your impending death I'll tell
you how each of them ends Billy Elliot
he becomes a professional dancer The
King's Speech the King delivers his
speech competently lost in translation
they kissed and he whispered something
in her ear you can't tell what it is
kinda bad it looks like each needs to be
alive I'll go ahead and notify your
family in alphabetical order
[Applause]
[Music]
started out so funny and then at the end
they didn't laugh at him hanging himself
what's wrong with everybody
haha hey what a great show we have
tonight from the hit what's your problem
I've never heard the band lab I found
what they like suicide this guy's still
laughing over here I love this guy this
guy right here he's good anyway